okay let's talk about something really
useful Google Fonts now back in 2010
Google started to offer web fonts for
free and it quickly became the biggest
repository the fastest repository for
free fonts to use on the web I can have
fonts installed on my computer that's
great that's wonderful and I can come in
here and I can say that I want to set
the font family to something that I have
installed on my computer that's gonna
work for me if I'm looking on my web
pages on my browser on my computer but
somebody else may not have that same
font installed that's why we build font
stacks with the fall backs google fonts
or web fonts in general this is how we
use some really nice fonts that are
available for free I could in theory
upload a font from my computer to a web
server link to it from there and that
anybody in the world can use it but if I
don't have a license for it then I'm
guilty of copyright infringement there
are fonts that are designed to be used
for print publishing there's fonts that
are designed to be used for the web
there's a ones that are free and there's
ones that are paid google fonts is a
collection of free ones you don't have
to pay anything to use them Google wants
people to use nicer fonts to have nicer
looking web pages so let's say for the
sake of argument that I'm building this
page and I want to use a serif font for
my headings and then I want to use a
sans serif font for my body text so I
have whatever my system wants to use is
the serif in the sans-serif right now
I'm gonna use google fonts to bring in
and use some nicer fonts so the website
fonts google.com pretty easy to remember
and this is what it looks like these are
different fonts samples of lots and lots
and lots and lots of different fonts you
can see how far I can scroll down here
there's tons of fonts available there's
a search as well that allows you to
narrow this down because if you
to really look at every font it would
take forever to you die of choices so
let's start with the serif we're gonna
try to find one for the heading so I
will unselect all the other categories
of fonts I only want to find a surf one
okay so in my serif groups here we can
scroll through starting to look for one
that we like or we can actually search
for if you know the name of a font so
here Vega Alegria I like this font so
I'm gonna take this one what I'm going
to do oh yeah and on the website here
you can also change the text that's
being displayed if you want to put in a
piece of text that you're going to be
using to see how that's going to render
you can do that so I'm gonna click the
plus sign right here to select it so I
have one family selected now now for the
body text I'm gonna have a serif font
for my headings and sans serif fonts for
my body text
so we'll unselect that go down to
sans-serif now the one I want to use is
called open sans here it is so open sans
now we can change the style of this to
see what it looks like but I'm just
gonna add this quickly and then click on
here to see here's the two fonts that
I've selected and these two fonts this
one's a serif font this is a sans serif
font I'm going to include these in my
webpages we can do the standard CSS I
can add a link tag I can copy and paste
this link tag put it into my page or if
you prefer the syntax for import we can
do that so I'm gonna do this one I'm
gonna copy that come over into here and
paste
there we are I have a net import that's
gonna bring in now let's expand this to
make it a little easier to read there we
are
so this is the URL that all of the fonts
begin with and then you'll have family
equals the names of the fonts if you
want to specify a specific weight we
could say instead of bringing down
everything let's only bring down 700
weight this is bold so I want the bold
Alegria and now I can come in here add
that to my list and font weight I will
set to 700 bolt okay I have that saved
I'll come take a look at my page there
we are this is the font so if we here
let's show both at the same time here
there we go
if I remove this there we go that's the
default serif and there it is with
Alegria we can do the same thing down
here this is the default sans-serif font
and then I will add open sans
there we are so there's my my font
pairing that I'm gonna use Alegria was
700 weight and open sans falling back to
sans-serif now I haven't done a full
font stack here I've just done a web
font and then a default inside here I've
done the basic includes for these things
we can also customize so with open sans
we're bringing down the regular width
Alegria I had said 700 that was what I
wanted now if I come back here you can
see there's the 400 and 700 I didn't
want the 400 I just wanted the 700 so I
put : 700 you can put a comma between
all the different weights if you want so
I can remove that regular I don't need
that and you'll see as you if you add in
all of these options this little thing
up here will change right now it says
load time slow because I'm loading all
these different versions if I didn't
bring all these versions ekits to become
a moderate load time and then a fast
load time so I'm bringing in two fonts
one font weight for each that's so fast
languages well do you just need the
Latin do you need the Latin extended do
you need Greek and Cyrillic as well so
depending on the font and depending on
the languages that you need you can do
this okay so I've got those selected one
other thing that it doesn't show in the
customization but you can actually limit
which text gets used I'm just gonna
slide this over a little bit there we
are we can come in here and say and text
equals there gnf Capital G capital F so
there's the capital G there's the
capital F and I'm only getting those two
letters being brought in that's the only
text that I'm that I'm bringing in those
are the only letters capital G capital F
those are the only ones that are being
brought in so the other letters are all
fallbacks
if I was to write out
there we've got Google written in
Alegria and now I've got fonts so this
would be an optimizing thing you can do
or it's something like if you want to do
that ransom note style where you've got
different letters for different things
you can limit which characters are
actually brought in as part of this so
that's the and text I will just leave it
as a comment here there we're okay so
we've got the Google font we did import
we could have brought it in as a link
tag as well we specified the weight that
we want we can specify that we only want
the 400 here we're speeding it up by
saying it's limited to just that weight
that's the default or we can say 500 or
400 that's the default weight that we're
getting in here step was to talk about
those fallback fonts
we've got Alegria we've got this the
generic we've got open sans we've got
the generic but there's nothing in
between so if this fails to load or if
it's really slow to load then we want to
have something that's much closer
matched to this so great website here
Meo need see a fantastic website here's
the web font I want Alegria that's the
one that I want and it's gonna download
it from Google Fonts we can play with
the size so let's go 24 pixel make this
easier to read there we are
line height you can play with the weight
so 700 is what we were using there we go
700 so Georgia it's okay we could take a
look at some other serif fonts to play
around with this times
times new roman'
so this is a San serif font Arial so you
can compare the difference this is how
you can go through if you've got a list
of fonts you want to compare it to you
can provide the names here to find
something that matches and then the
section down here at the bottom over
left this is showing the same text with
both fonts so options you can show them
in different colors so red for one black
for the other and then this creates a
little animation so you can see the
difference fo you C stands for flash of
unstyled content so you see one while
the web font is loading and then it
quickly changes the goal of this is to
have something that doesn't dramatically
change like if I were to come in here
and say okay this one's 16 pixels that
one's 38 pixels there you can see huge
change between the two fonts this is not
an effect that you want to have you want
to get these things as close as possible
to one another so that as you are
styling in whatever font size you're
picking it's the saint's it's gonna be
the same font size regardless of the
font so you want to make sure that these
two things are pretty close to one
another now this is a bad match you
would never replace Alegria with Arial
but Palatino Georgia something like that
this is something that you could use as
a replacement font all right so that's
google fonts I will include the links
for this great tool the links to the
google fonts website and a code pen for
this code so you can play around with it
if you have any questions feel free to
leave them in the comments below if you
found this useful please share it with
other people and as always thanks for
watching